[ __ ] him my whole life I thought a man
was a tough guy I'm not tough guy I even
thought that that was something to
esteem I'm not interested in tough I
don't care if you can run ultra marathon
I care how creative you are yeah that's
what's interesting to me goddammit I
feel like singing a song I get my back
into my little bed I just wrote that ice
you wow that was me just out there right
and you channeled it can I be honest
with you yeah that's right like the
Russian mathematician [ __ ] that's
right right that's right I saw you do um
I don't know what it was I think Saab
had it on his Instagram you were singing
that's mother I did that a goddamn
Comedy Jam really yeah where which one
in Austin oh I did the televised one I
won't do it and this is national I know
yeah that was super mean of you and I
was about doping I was about to brag and
then you cut my lip no I thought it was
good I thought I go that's good for that
if I ran it 150 people that watch if
we're gonna [ __ ] oh my god watch mine oh
my god we're in a boxing match and you
sweep my leg yeah I did yeah well I mean
we wouldn't be fighting because I'm at a
higher level
yeah
you're kind of sending what song did you
sing I don't even remember that's how a
little like hair again I just did it
Yerevan
I you know what Chris D'Elia does to me
he'll just send a picture of just a
brick of hundreds right here right
you're poor you know what he did once he
sent me a photo of his dogs right but
they're all on a pile of money
look I'll keep my ducks
Billy is like he wrapped his hard-on in
a sheet and he goes dude so that was
good I saw that you know man
I'm gonna fight you weight class I think
oh they both wrestle in high school how
much you want 73 I was 67 160 so that's
[ __ ] an attack or a legit 125 yeah if
you had to fight you have to talk to 25
yeah I would I'm just not I don't have a
fight schedule I'd have to talk to 45
and maybe even 35 yeah I still win but
do you like the UFC I made you a fan of
it yeah I'm a huge fan
you all good I'm a huge fan of like
mixed martial arts it's so hard yeah
yeah you know when you did that warrior
movie did you ever meet Tom Hardy yeah I
spent two months but he's a great guy he
seemed he was not famous when I know why
but I we knew he was going to be yeah
you could tell though well there's also
buzz CIA was like he's the prince but
believe me the machine was already
working about six movies lined up for
that guy yeah after Bronson he's a great
guy but he I saw him first on that Star
Trek movie well he look yeah wood ball
deeply played on young as a young man
he's just [ __ ] really good lives
though way better than even great
congratulations leo we don't fastly on
the show hey come on specifics related
you're not bashing one of the best
actors of our generation right dude who
you talking to you know the snake he is
Leslie I don't know about that
okay anyway it's not you yet Tommy how
hard has nothing on you he's good too
stop talking to him like you're friends
with another guy that was it I like him
too
joel edgerton is that his name [ __ ]
Australian actor yeah really good nice
great guy it's just a real great guy
everyone stop who else knew something
does stop thinking right now I don't
like your [ __ ] what did you invited
me in your own I know but you get
introspective and you're like all cools
and then you know what the seniors
you're you know what a [ __ ] hand
that's the thing you'd the mathematician
[ __ ] and the [ __ ] coming to you ain't
going into a log cabin away mom [ __ ] you
I read read I know but you know what
come on what your old friends yeah but
you know what you need to be educated
and can I ask you another question yeah
[ __ ] is with your house too many cars
too many colors in boy boy boy bro
you're becoming a skinhead boy let us in
man don't you do that to me let me see
something me alright mate you look like
shut the [ __ ] up for a second alright
this is my house okay you don't ever
make fun of a man's house alright
excited alright alright your mouth lost
the [ __ ] out dogging the [ __ ] and
crossed the [ __ ] line do you have hot
alright Korea no nobody knows me that
are you a [ __ ] superstar in [ __ ]
Norway or your [ __ ] from the doorway
he's probably I'm southern Italian and
Irish [ __ ]
and yes the answer is yes Suton came
yeah I went to your house you probably
different house we used to live in
Venice or Santa Monica which one
dimension or the other man other magic
this is before you know what Bernal
Santa Monica
yeah but I were you invited me to that
Super Bowl party do you remember yeah
you do no yeah you did you did you come
I didn't come did you like it I stayed
but that hurts that you don't remember
about now yeah but I remember going to I
didn't know you that well but you
invited me and I went to your house and
I think I left in about 15 minutes
why because I don't know how football is
played you little [ __ ] non-american
yeah so I was like I can't do this I
didn't know who the team you should be
vetted I bet it for what for your
citizenry I don't know yeah I was born
you're [ __ ] up you want me to stand up
again who are you with I just got the
OCA right really a movie great thanks
it's amazing you're CIA too right yeah
you know just asked if I still have his
credit card president I know that's
another thing that's another thing
because I see sometimes I'm at the
Comedy Store and you'll be with Jeremy
Piven yeah but you guys will be off in
the corner yeah that's how he's
whispering about things yeah about the
business about know I always wonder what
are you whispering about really like
what to do with our money and how to
keep people of
[Laughter]
[Music]